if the pictures tell their story in
syria so do ever-worsening statistics on
deaths injuries and the flight of
millions to safety it is estimated that
6.8 million people in syria that is
almost one-third of the population
have been affected by the conflict
including more than 4.2 million
displaced people inside syria
parliament's human rights committee this
week hosted two syrian activists with
very different demands mustafa haid
director of daulati which promotes human
rights and non-violent activism demanded
that member states call perpetrators of
war crimes to account at the
international criminal court farah hui
called for special support for women and
civil society
we have registered many cases that prove
the spread of sexual violence being used
as an instrument of war
terrorizing women and their society
it is considered one of the main reasons
why millions of people are fleeing the
country and have become internally
displaced
there's talk of green shoots of economic
recovery in europe but workers are still
finding themselves jobless needing
practical and financial support from the
globalization adjustment fund
wednesday's budgets committee allocated
more than a million euros for almost 500
workers from two electronics enterprises
in italy's prosperous north jobless
after their firms were shut down it was
part of a 3.7 million euro package to
help 1500 redundant italian workers
uh
europe